a new front page report in the new york
times finds that more companies are
monitoring and recording employees to
measure their productivity journalist
jody cantor investigates the rise of
so-called productivity scores these can
be measured with trackers that log
keyboard activity and screenshot
employees faces and computer screens and
workers can lose points if they're
deemed inactive that can mean you
stepped away to get a coffee it can mean
you're going to mentor a co-worker
you're not at your computer for some
cantor found that low scores can mean
less pay or even getting fired losing
their jobs employees in a wide range of
industries we're talking architecture
the healthcare describe this as being
tracked as demoralizing humiliating and
toxic and jody cantor joins us now uh
jody as i said in the green room i think
this is one of those articles that's
going to be pulled for decades and
decades to look at where we're going as
a country and where it began
we heard some employees complain i can
understand those complaints let's talk
about the employer side though what's
the case for doing this you know one of
the most interesting parts of this
reporting was talking to the people who
really believe in these systems they say
first of all that it's inevitable that
the workplace has become a place of
measurement don't fool yourself they say
that it's more transparent that the
person who's a great contributor but
maybe kind of quiet can be recognized by
these systems and they say and they gave
me examples
people really do cheat there are
derelict workers who even for example
are taking two remote jobs at once and
not really doing either of them
and they also say that they can manage
better when they really see what people
are doing when in detail but then on the
other hand we found an avalanche of
really disturbing stories of people who
felt that they couldn't really do their
jobs well with these systems or that the
measurements were just wrong and i want
to be clear this is something that was
more prevalent in low-income jobs for a
long time
now we're seeing it with people with
college degrees graduate degrees even
hospice chaplains who had to earn
productivity points as they tended to
the dying so depending on what they do
they get points for the care they
administer i did not know that there was
a whole chart you know point two five
points for a condolence call one point
for a visit to the dying but like
idle time could mean anything though and
you can also be productive
during that idle time that's because and
the face isn't there or not your you
don't see my strokes doesn't mean i'm
not working this is only measuring
digital activity so we found some very
frustrated social workers working for a
big fortune 500 company this is very
mainstream and they were marked as being
idle which is a judgmental word that's
like derelict while they were actually
seeing patients in drug treatment
facilities
but it's just that their laptops weren't
out and they weren't typing at the time
you ever hear of employees that say you
know i actually think this is a good
idea we do we found some that craved
more tracking why well for example i
talked to a woman who said i am doing
more on my team than my male co-worker
who i believe is going to the beach
based on his instagram posts and i wish
there was a system that recognized that
i'm the real contributor i bet there
wasn't many of those though right some
some
some but the majority of people we talk
to are incredibly frustrated with this
because people um
people feel that agency and decision
making has been taken from them and that
this is a very intimate form of control
in which it was like an invasion almost
right and that i mean we talked to tons
of workers who are having problems with
bathroom breaks that used to be a
warehouse worker problem does the
company have to tell you that they're
monitoring you depending on which state
you live in really yeah what about new
york state if you work for a big media
company
i mean one of the big worries i think is
that it distorts the job itself i was
struck by the uh the kroger uh workers
who are doing grocery checkout and they
got to be fast well sometimes they can't
be fast because they've got an elderly
patron the customer service involves
chit chatting and going in they're just
explaining that the coupons don't apply
to this yes yeah exactly or with those
chaplains if you're shopping safe for
shoes can the employees tell you're
looking at shoes
depending on the program just asking for
friends so so part of why this was
complicated to report on is that it's
not one piece of software right it's not
facebook you know or twitter which we
can scrutinize as one program this is
like a million different kinds of
software that do this and some of them
gail yes do
screenshot some screenshot every 10
minutes like at a random time so even if
you were working for nine minutes and 55
seconds
if that screenshot shows you looking for
those shoes or just getting interrupted
by a text from your kid or something you
may not not get paid for that feels
inevitable which is why i think this is
such an historic piece yeah thank you so
much
again be right back